何見よっかなー
いやなんか今週ってワンピースまだマジ
やばいどう思ってる4大じゃんあー今週の
やつはまだ読んでない
えっまだ呼んでないってあ時間なかった
からねまあそうだよね
先週やばかったんだけどね
ごめん先週のやつも見てないんでねあそれ
も
連続に結構2週間で忙しかったからみたい
な感じねそうだね
終わったからいやなんかどう思いますか
なんか本当にやばかったんですね
だよねえっとね
今日俺見てないんだね
ちょっと待って見てないってあ
漫画読むことでみたいな感じでねあ漫画派
だからなるほどねはい
助けになんか俺もいいかなんか個人アニメ
よりは漫画の方がまあ
好きなんだけどねええと一般的にね
本当にそう思いました
ワンピース
自体はまだ読めてないっていう
あっあっなんかあそっかタイムスキップ
からまだ呼んでないドフラミンゴすごかっ
たね
っていうのはでもアドが大好きだよあ
介護すごかったですねなんか
映画もいや本当にわかったんだ一番好きな
記憶を何だっけあ
うっせーわあったかいやそれはまあいいや
好きなキャラクターとかありますか
ルフィ
はやっぱり1回でもワンピース読んだこと
ないですよおかしいじゃなんか子供っぽく
てちょっと待っていつでもその
ストーリーのコースは大事とか
伏線もなんか大事って話ししてるもん